well American politics is once again
ground to a halt thanks to the action of
a man who's being described as a
whistleblower a federal employee who
disagreed with the president's policy on
Ukraine we know almost nothing about
this person we say man it could be a
woman context is important is this
person of partisan how much access did
he or she have what exactly are his or
her motives it would be nice to know all
of that as we assess the current
impeachment congressman Devin Nunez sits
on the House Intelligence Committee
which is the epicenter of course the
impeachment inquiry he joins us tonight
congressman thanks so much for coming on
what why can't we know more about this
person being described as the
whistleblower exactly you know this is a
very good question because as far as I'm
concerned the Inspector General of the
intelligence agencies is obstructing our
investigation which i think is a is a
crime it is not okay for only one party
to know about the whistleblower
furthermore the Democrats on the
committee and their staff who seem to
know the whistleblower they also won't
won't tell us now here's what's
interesting about the point you made I
know there's lots of speculation out
there about who the whistleblower may be
right I'm not a lawyer but unfortunately
I have to hang out with a bunch of
lawyers and I say that halfway joking
and only halfway joking but what the
lawyers tell me is is that this would
not be admissible in court you cannot
take hearsay from us suppose that
somebody who we've never met we just
can't take the word of some lawyer and
and the IG and the Democrats on the
committee this person has to have a name
they have to actually exist for this to
be considered real evidence in an
investigation well yeah I mean so the
hyannis on television are jumping up and
down hyperventilating telling so how
dare you want to know the identity it
could endanger that person which frankly
a little insulting to those of us who
give us our opinions every day kind of
out there you do it everyone knows your
name everyone knows where you live like
if you have an opinion stand up and be
counted for it
America but it doesn't really answer the
question how can we assess the claims
this person has made if we don't know
who this person is or where he's coming
from if this person is in fact a hard
partisan isn't that relevant to the case
that's a sincere question there you
you've answered your own question we
cannot we cannot even begin this is why
we continue to say that Adam Schiff and
or his staff whoever has met with the
whistleblower they are fact foundational
witnesses to this disaster okay okay so
like the truth is you know is that we
have a pretty good idea a lot of us do
and all these news organizations are
being bullied in effect by Adam Schiff
by the the power of his aggression in
the boldness of his claims you can't do
that you're putting a man's life in
danger really what do you be quiet you
demagogue like why are we allowing
ourselves to be bullied by this guy
seriously and remember it and let's just
talk about the hypocrisy of this it was
only a couple months ago that there was
this supposed informant that was that
was you know extracted out of Russia and
you had all the major newspapers you
know
showing his name going to his house
taking pictures and so sometimes it's a
when the mainstream media wants to out a
whistleblower because they thought or
wants to learn about and inform it
because it's a Russian who might have
something bad to do with Trump then they
do it but if it's somebody who clearly I
think look they're telling us exactly
what we need to know and that is that
this whoever this whistleblower is must
be an extreme partisan with lots of
problems with their story that's why
that the whistleblower is not coming
forward well it sounds like the
whistleblower and I hate the term
because if the person who's being
identified as a so-called whistleblower
he's in fact that person he's not a
whistleblower at all he's a guy who
disagrees with Trump's foreign policy
views okay
so that's not you know that's not a
whistleblower but do you think that the
person being described in some news
stories and all over Twitter
is that the whistle the so-called
whistleblower because if it is that
guy's a serious partisan well look
regardless the person that is being
described whether it's the whistleblower
or not we have no way to know okay
yeah the person who is being described
that nobody wants to say the name that
person has got to come and testify
whether they like it or not for sure
they're gonna come and testify now if if
Schiff doesn't let that person and the
Democrats in the house don't let that
person come and testify to the house I
guarantee you if they impeach that
person will have to be called to the
city and it's Alinejad put words in
mitch mcconnell's mouth but yeah should
he absolutely should have to yeah and
I'm not naming because I can't get
anyone to confirm that it's really him
sounds like it's him but I don't want to
say it unless I can get because
information but I mean at some point you
can say it's in the government exactly
but it goes back to what we were just
talking about right now there truly is
no whistleblower okay there is only a
whistleblower in paper okay there is no
evidence right now not until both
parties we have a system in this country
I've been I've been doing this for a
while now I've been dealing with
whistleblowers you have to allow the
whistleblowers whoever that may be to
come to both parties exactly and if
you're not doing that there is something
wrong there's somebody's life's in NATO
Jeremy here live my life for a week yeah
Devon it's great to see you tonight
thanks so much appreciate it always a
pleasure thank you